the Scarlet rot is one of the deadliest
things in the lands between four it has
no real cure and famously even the
demigods could not Stave off its effects
I guess no one told them about
preserving boluses huh anyway what's
really interesting about the Scarlet rot
is that it's actually a very old Legend
one that predates Melania and all of the
horrors found in caled and so to
understand where it all began we have to
go below to the lake of rot where we can
find a few item descriptions that speak
of this time for example here in the
Southeastern Corner we can loot a crown
of mushrooms that forms this towering
headpiece and it reads long ago great
Lords served the Scarlet rot perhaps
such fungal bodies served as their
crowns and the rest of this set is made
up of the mushroom set which are
considered holy vestments for those in
raptured by the Scarlet rot that route
them to the Earth so already we have
this hierarchy of mushroom Lords that
served the Scarlet rot back then as well
as worshipers who venerated it and you
might think it's strange that these
beings might worship or serve a sickness
but the Scarlet rot is so much more than
that because the Scarlet rot is no mere
disease
now for proof of that one only need to
look at the crystalline crystalline are
inorganic beings and yet they can be
afflicted by the rot just like any other
there's even some crystallians that are
infused with rot and can spread it to
others as well because it's not really
just a disease instead the map for the
lake of rot calls it the Divine Essence
of an outer God something that was
sealed away long ago in this underground
world and if you've been following Elden
ring law for any length of time you
should be no stranger to the concept of
an outer God they are these
indeterminable abstract beings that
impress an order or a will upon the
world through their avatars their
servants and their vessels and in the
case of the Scarlet rot its order is one
of Decay where beings are put into a
progressing state of death with the
intent to achieve this glorious rebirth
that will follow that process the poison
Armament description tells us this
saying that those who dwell within
poison no rot All Too Well the death
that begets life that comes to all
equally that is to say it is the cycle
of rebirth put into practice a great
example of this is Nicholas halictry
which might be completely dead were it
not for the fungal growths that have
sprouted upon the tree and of course we
also see this in caled where flowers of
the rot are on the very precipice of
budding despite all the decay of course
it's debatable whether this type of life
is even desirable at all but you can't
argue that it is life and the Agents of
the rot God certainly find it desirable
so they do their utmost to spark this
sacred cycle of rebirth in others
infecting them with poison and rot and
putting the cycle of rebirth into
practice on that note there is one
extremely curious item that you can find
down in the grand Cloister and it's
called the scorpion Stinger this is a
dagger that's glistening with Scarlet
rot and it's called a ceremonial tool
which I think means that any ceremony
that used this dagger would have been a
ceremony to stab and infect another
being with the Scarlet rot it would have
been a ceremony of spreading their
treasured Affliction to others but
what's really interesting about this
dagger is that it's fashioned from a
great Scorpion's tale and it's also
specifically said to have been crafted
from the relic of a sealed outer God and
when you consider that phrasing it makes
you realize that it's saying that this
dagger was fashioned from a relic of the
rothgod who was also a great scorpion
that's what it sounds like it's saying
anyway I mean many historical relics in
our history are often the physical
remains of deceased Saints or holy
persons so the god of rot might really
be or at least might have met invested
as a great scorpion so I guess this
scorpion Stinger is kind of like the eye
of the fell God or the three fingers of
frenzy or the whole winged theme the
death has going on it's a small
remaining hint at the visual identity of
these ephemeral outer gods that is
intended to stimulate the imagination
even if we never truly find out what
these outer gods look like
and whatever rot truly is it and its
Scarlet rot Essence was eventually
conquered or sealed at least this was
done by a legendary figure known as The
Blind Swordsman as The Story Goes The
Blind Swordsman was favored by a fairy
called the dancer in blue the fairy
bestowed upon them a flowing curved
sword which was patterned after flowing
water and with this sword the blind
swordsman sealed away an ancient god a
God that was rot itself there's quite a
bit to unpack in these descriptions
first who or what was the fairy called
the Blue dancer well I think that the
Warrior's blue cloth set gives us a clue
it reveals that the blue color of its
fabric symbolizes brisk Waters and the
cloth doll that represents the blue
dancer is styled to look just like water
the description goes on to say that just
as Still Waters turn and foul stagnation
leads to Decay so Warriors must remain
ever drifting it's essentially saying
that flowing water is the very
antithesis to rot which thrives in
stagnant water and I think and this is
just speculation but I think that the
Blue Fairy might essentially be a sort
of River Spirit if you've ever seen
Hayao miyazaki's Spirited Away then you
might know what type of being I'm
talking about in that movie Just quickly
a stinking sludge monster comes to the
bath house where it is eventually
revealed that it's actually a River
Spirit whose River was bogged down and
corrupted by pollution but once his
waters are unblocked the River Spirit is
restored and Elden ring by comparison
does also have two legendary Rivers
called the shifra and the angel which
just so happened to flow underground
next to and around the Scarlet rot that
was a eventually sealed all that time
ago so I don't think that it's a stretch
to think that the Blue Fairy might have
occupied or might have been a
supernatural extension of those
underground Rivers I think it's a fun
Theory and I think it helps to explain
the blue fairy's relationship with water
and why it might be a natural enemy of
the rod God so the Blue Fairy gave the
blind swordsman a flowing sword and he
fought with the power of flowing water
to seal away the rod God but what's
unclear here is how exactly the Scarlet
Rock God was sealed Away by the blind
swordsman did he you know sword in hand
battle a great scorpion boss in
one-on-one combat and just seal its
Essence away or was their battle more of
an abstract one where the Eternal City
dams were built and rivers were rerouted
to encircle the rot and contain it
underground or something like that these
details are left your imagination but
one way or another Scarlett Rod God was
sealed away but it was not defeated and
eventually it would return and this time
it would do so in an Imperium vessel
corrupting Millennia a demigod at the
very moment of her birth
like her brother mikola Melania was born
an Imperium imperian meaning she was
essentially a valid candidate to replace
Queen Marica as a God and as such it
seems she was a ripe candidate for an
outer God's meddling and it's unclear
how The rotcod Afflicted Melania as soon
as she was born but it did end that's a
shame because melania's great Rune does
state that it should have been the most
sacred great Rune of them all were it
not for what I assume was the rotcods
meddling and speaking of great runes in
the Sister video to this one we talk
about how mikola was essentially the
flip side to Millennia in many ways
especially in Cut content where the
Twins were born of an Inseparable fate
and said to hold the Runes of both
abundance and Decay between them and to
reflect this Duality it seems mikola is
in this constant state of overflowing
abundance while Melania was in this
constant state of overflowing death
essentially we sort of see this tragedy
unfolding in a few statues of Melania
since you can see back then she did
actually have all her limbs once upon a
time until the Rocks continued to take
hold moving her inexorably towards her
inevitable death and rebirth as well and
that must have felt inevitable for it
seems like in these early days there
were few known ways to ward off the rot
fire was probably the obvious one and
then there was also the act of
consecration which was used which is
essentially the act of declaring
something as sacred which was done to
the Weaponry of Melania and her Knights
and apparently it helped their armaments
at least to resist the rod but their
flesh was still susceptible millennia's
Knights were therefore called the clean
rot nights and they vowed to fight
alongside Melania despite the inevitable
if gradual putrefaction of their flesh
and it was this fact that made these
Warriors so Fierce for they had
basically already accepted their
terrible fate and so logically they had
nothing else to lose in battle these
nights were bestowed the winged sword
Insignia given only to those who fought
alongside Melania the seven
interestingly this is the only item that
gives Melania the title the seven and I
assume that it's referencing a time
where Melania was known for her prowess
despite her fragmented body as it's
called in the Japanese and I guess it's
possible that she wasn't yet known as
the blade of Michela at the time though
that's just my own speculation at any
rate Melania blade of Nicola is her most
common title and it's easy to see why
she would dedicate herself to her
brother so fully for her brother was so
dismayed by her condition that he
dedicated himself to finding a treatment
for the rot and this search for a cure
dramatically affected Nicola's world
view for instance he was formerly a
faithful fundamentalist of the golden
order with all the magic to boot but he
would abandon those practices as they
could do nothing to treat his sisters a
cursed rot instead he pursued a path of
unalloid gold and he crafted four
Millennia a needle that could be
inserted into her flesh granting relief
from the rot and preventing the
progression of the rotting sickness if
you're interested in why unalloid gold
was able to do this and work that way
then I'd recommend you check out this
video afterwards which talks at length
about mikola but we learn about the
needles specific effects in game when we
give it to a character called Millicent
who is also suffering from the Scarlet
rot Millicent is this great parallel to
Melania that teaches us so much about
what Melania might have felt or
experienced so Millicent 2 has lost a
limb and she is also losing her memories
and when we find her she is unable to
even move but as soon as we give her the
needle she's able to function and fight
once more therefore it's fair to assume
that similar benefits were conferred
upon Millennia when her brother gave her
the needle it's also worth noting that
the multiple needles that we find in
game they aren't finished even the final
version of this needle can only be used
in the storm Beyond Time at faroom Azula
where it allows you to cheat fate
essentially and that makes sense here
because you're outside of time in this
place so maybe you can prevent these
afflictions from the outer Gods before
they even happen so perhaps if mikola
had been able to imbue his needle with
some some time warping capabilities he
could have eventually undone the effects
of the rod God entirely but again the
needle was unfortunately never finished
the needle isn't all that Michael are
created with unalloid gold he also
crafted for his sister a prosthetic arm
leg helmet and armor of unalloid gold
which again like Millicent surely
allowed her to overcome her one-armed
shortcoming and reach for newer Heights
as a fighter so melania's prospects were
already looking up but things didn't end
there for Millennia would go on to meet
a man who would become her mentor and he
would give her this final invaluable
tool that could be employed against the
Scarlet rot we see their meeting play
out on this image of the prosthesis
wearer heirloom which depicts a scene
from a heroic tale you can even see
melania's prosthetic arm and leg in this
image if you look closely which is why I
assume that this meeting took place
after mikola's intervention with all of
the unalloid gold Prosthetics so her
Mentor was as you might have guessed the
blind swordsman the man who first sealed
away the rot all those years ago the
very same and after encountering her
mental and his flowing blade she gained
wings of unparalleled strength this
meeting says a lot about the blind
swordsman he must have known that
Millennia was basically an inhabited by
his ancient enemy and yet he doesn't
attempt to kill her here instead he
takes her under his wing and teaches her
the techniques that he himself once used
to curtail the rot in the first place
it's a pretty wise thing to do and
perhaps we shouldn't expect any less
from someone who was able to defeat an
outer God in the first place so this is
why the skill on melania's blade is
called the waterfowl dance this is why
Millennia recovers Health by attacking
during her boss fight by moving
relentlessly like flowing water the
damage of the rot was offset and Melania
was able to achieve unparalleled
strength and to maintain her Pride but
it was that same Pride that she would
abandon in her fight with radon
foreign
[Music]
was born of Queen Ronaldo who was the
queen of karia and King consort Radigan
who was previously a great champion of
the earth tree thus was the order of the
moon and the hood tree conjoined and
while Rodan was a truecarion and
certainly proficient in the art of
sorcery we can see in his character an
inclination towards another path an
aspiration to be like Godfrey for
example who was the first Elden Lord and
also his father Radigan who would become
the second Eldon Lord karya was after
all a largely matriarchal society
meaning that power was passed down to
the princesses in the family so perhaps
it's no surprise that radon was not as
motivated by his carrion Heritage
compared to his sister Rani for instance
so radan set was decorated with a Golden
Lion that symbolized Godfrey and his
Beast Regent and it states that from his
youngest years Rodan was naturally
captivated by the lord of the
battlefield then his golden helmet was
designed with his flaming red hair in
mind which Rodan inherited from his
father drawing attention to the fact
that he was fond of the heroic
implications of being radigan's son
radan and his Knights were fittingly
known as the red Mane which conflates
rodan's red hair with the Mane of
Godfrey's lion and Rodan was even quoted
as saying I was born a Champions Cup now
I am the lord of the battlefield's lion
which borders on being a statement of
complete loyalty to Godfrey and the
golden order but we'll get to that
debate a little bit later
so naturally this was a guy who reveled
in the art of warfare and even in his
youth as a carrion Royal it seems radon
was already a renowned General we can
infer this because of a man named Jaron
the eccentric's armor specifically says
that after spending time as a guest of
the carrion Royals he became a guest
Commander for General radon therefore
Redan must have still been in close
contact with his karian family as jiren
met radan through these carrion Royals
and when they did meet Jaron and radon
seemed to immediately share a certain
bond for despite jiren preferring to
have a nomadic existence he decided to
become a guest Commander for General
radon and then despite the temporary
implication of such a title gerund this
Restless Tumbleweed as he was called
would become Bound by honorable oath and
he and radan swore a vow of honorable
death to one another promising that they
would die honorably in battle even if it
was death by the other's hand so it's
not stated which battles that bradan was
fighting at the time Norwich War he
required a new guest Commander for but
then the world was very different at the
time and there's so much of the lens
between history that we don't know about
so I guess it's possible that the
battles were being fought for distant
lands like Lim grave and Khalid the Lim
grave East map does say after all that
this path here was trod by many a
soldier in the past maybe redan's forces
took this path as well and this was
before Caleb was even Afflicted with the
Scarlet Rock so things might have looked
really different here although
admittedly we do have this shot from
this trailer that shows that it still
kind of looks a bit like a red hellscape
here with the red sky and this was
technically before the Scarlet rot took
hold caled did still have some culture
to boast of though for example in the
very middle of caled there is or was a
town of sorcery called Celia and despite
rodan's relationship with karya and Raya
lucaria as well presumably it was here
in Celia that he studied learning
gravitational Magics that likely could
not be taught anywhere else he did this
as The Story Goes also he would never
have to abandon his beloved but scrawny
Steed for gravitational Magics could
relieve the weight of radon and allow
his scrawny horse to carry him ever more
also in case you don't know the horse's
name is Leonard according to the data so
that is the name that we're going to use
going forward and what's interesting
about Leonard is that he specifically
called out as being scrawny as if that's
the reason why he can't carry red Don
who is enormous shouldn't radan's size
be the reason why he can't ride his
horse so I think personally that radon
actually didn't become as large as he is
for a very long time and I think there's
some good evidence to back that up for
one he's thrown in Landell is of regular
size two his portrait is of a simple
grown man and lastly we see a brief shot
of Rodan fighting in this image where he
barely even matches morgot in size so
personally I think that radon probably
only grew in size when he acquired a
great Rune regardless at this stage
anyway it's clear that bradan initially
learned gravitational magic for the sake
of his horse but that gravitational
skill set would certainly come in handy
as the years went on for one these
gravitational Magics were passed on to
some of his elite soldiers like ogre who
was the longest serving member of the
red main Knights who studied techniques
to manipulate gravity alongside radon
the equipment and the skill sets of the
red made Knights really were very
inspired by radon for example the
circuit of rodan's red maid Knights
depicts a red maned lion raising a sword
in the image of radon all of them proved
that they were worthy of the red main
name even their great Shield's design
takes that symbolism further being
shaped like a Fang and featuring the
crest of a red maned lion and these
Knights were strong like radon too with
descriptions stating that they were
reputed to be masterful Warriors and it
was popularly said that the red Mains
knew no weakness but for all of their
prowess in battle a conflict was coming
that no military strength could Ward
away and I'm not talking about the
Scarlet rot I'm talking about the stars
but luckily for this upcoming conflict
radan was able to solicit the help of an
extremely knowledgeable teacher
according to the gravity well sorcery
rodan's master was an alabaster Lord
with skin of stone and these Onyx and
alabaster Lords Were A different race
entirely to humans and were said to have
risen to life when a meteor struck long
ago and the meteorite sorcery tells us
that the reason they were called Lords
was in reverential fear of their
destructive power and it seems like
radon was soliciting their help because
a similarly meteoric destructive power
was on its way to Celia so earlier we
established that he explicitly did learn
gravitational magic so that he could
ride his horse but the collapsing star's
sorcery also explicitly says that he
learned gravitational techniques so that
he could challenge the Stars which I
think suggests that there were two
distinct periods of learning here for
Radon learning for the sake of his horse
and then learning for the same sake of
keeping Celia safe and there's also
quite a bit of evidence that suggests
that radon's actions here were in
defense for example the sword gravestone
in caled specifically tells us that
radon held Celia secure the star Scourge
heirloom tells us that Rodan confronted
the falling stars as if they were the
aggressors finally this event was also
called the star Scourge conflict
suggesting that there was a clash of
some kind here like a back and forth if
you will so radon seemed to anticipate
that this event was coming but I guess
that isn't so strange when you consider
that radon was of karyan lineage who
were renowned for reading Fate In The
Stars so I would think that anticipating
a Starfall would be pretty
straightforward for them and I think it
would make sense that radon would want
to intervene if it was headed for Celia
which is where he learned his magic from
in the first place so Redan took
defensive measures and I guess you might
argue that he even went a bit overboard
for he didn't just defend Celia from the
falling stars he actually sealed the
star's movements completely so after
Rodan challenged the Stars the Fate in
the night sky was said to be no more and
this manifests quite literally in rani's
quest line for example where Redan has
to be killed so that the Stars can be
unfrozen so that one of them can
literally smash into limb grave and open
a path to nocron if not foradan I feel
like a star would have smashed through
Celia instead and opened a path to
nokron that way all those years ago the
Eternal City of nokron is said after all
to sleep below Celia so radan really
might have intervened here at the very
last moment
star is released and hits Lim grave as
soon as you kill radon though I'll admit
that it is a bit strange that that star
hits Lim grave and not Celia which he
was said to defend I wonder why anyway
there's one more thing I want to talk
about here and it's that you could also
make the argument that bradan might have
intervened at Celia and Frozen the Stars
on behalf of the golden order after all
the telescope item description literally
says that the Fate once writ in the
night skies was fettered by the golden
order and radan was a fanboy of Radigan
and Godfrey who were two proponents of
the golden order so it's definitely
possible that he did this on the golden
order's behalf
personally though I think that both
things can be true I think that radon
was clearly motivated to defend Celia
from Starfall and I think that the
golden order did stand to benefit from
one of its vassals achieving such a feat
radan and most of the demigods at that
stage for that matter were technically
on the side of America's golden order so
I guess technically radon was aligned
with the golden order and could have
fettered the Stars on their behalf
technically but the impression that I
get from radon is that he has no real
loyalty to anyone other than himself and
his men
is my speculation but I think this
because he's not really hated by anyone
in the current age or anyone in game
even his brother reichardt has his
picture up on the wall and reichardt
famously hated anything to do with the
golden order so while I think Rodan
served the intent of the golden order I
don't think he was beholden to it
especially not in the later years when
the Eldon ring was shattered because
remember this cutscene with morgot
willful traitors or
or mogot labels all of the demigods as
traitors to the golden order including
Rodan who we do see in a clash with
morgot suggesting that he might have
abandoned his loyalty to order and
marched on Landell after the shattering
before radan like his demigod kin had
claimed a great Rune and it's easy to
assume that a warmonger like him would
have had great Ambitions for power and
might have even aspired to become Eldon
Lord and it's around this time when the
demigods were clashing that Melania
enters the picture once more because
Melania blade of Michela was marching
towards caled past godric in Lim grave
and towards Redan
foreign
nothing more than a jumped up country
bumpkin
Lord oh don't make me laugh
first he hid himself amongst the women
folk to flee the capital then hid from
redone in that castle then he insulted
Melania lost to her in battle only to
lick her boots rather than die like a
man
has seen no shame the big girl's blouse
this dialogue from Kenneth height is a
great piece of law as it tells us about
this crucial late part of the shattering
War at this point godric had just failed
to usurp Langdale capital and had fled
with his tail between his legs to
Stormville here he hid in fear of Rodan
who was a close neighbor in caled and it
makes sense that he'd fear radan who was
considered by many to be the strongest
of the demigods but while he was hiding
here a different Army approached from
the north not the South as godric must
have feared Melania and her clean rot
Knights were passing stormvale on their
southwards March from the hay League
tree to Caleb and this event this
passing is marked at the Leonia Highway
sword gravestones which state nothing
will hinder the wings of the blade of
mikola and the clean rot Knights
these gravestones tend to mark points of
battle and Kenneth does state that
godric insulted Melania and lost to her
in battle so I assume this is where that
happened as to the nature of the insult
well we have cut dialogue from godric to
help us out here
there is only one tree and only its
branches that bathe in true Rays of gold
not the full Omen King nor the rank
malformed twins
so godric considered mikola and Melania
Rank and malformed so I assume the
insult was along those lines which was
not smart on godric's part Millennia
must have messed him up but tellingly
she did not kill him and that's a
curious detail because this was the
shattering War we're supposed to believe
that all of the demigods were fighting
for power but if Melania was seeking
power here and looking for others great
runes to acquire in order to restore the
Elden ring and live up to mikola or her
own imperian promise then you'd think
that she would have killed godric that
she wouldn't have shown him Mercy but
instead she lets him live so to me that
suggests that Millennia might not have
been on this Southward march to take
power because if she didn't claim
godric's great Rune then she probably
wasn't here for a dance either so why
then why did Melania come full force
towards radon on this Southward March I
feel like there are three options four
if you count the theory that Millennia
might have chased down radon in order to
get control of the olden ring but as
I've just explained I feel like that's
unlikely option two although it's still
unlikely in my opinion is that Millennia
might have sought out pradan Simply for
the sake of fighting him he was after
all widely considered the mightiest of
the demigods as was Melania in many
cases so it's not ridiculous to think
that both of them might have fought
simply for the sake of pitting their
strength against one another but that's
a pretty unsatisfactory answer in my
opinion option three I feel could be
because Melania was looking for her
brother at this point mikola could have
already been stolen away by Moog so
perhaps she was simply looking for him
she pretty intentionally makes a beeline
towards the South and towards caled and
moog's Palace is essentially underneath
Celia and underneath the area where
Redan and Melania fought so I guess it's
possible that Melania had some Intel
leading her here in a search for mikola
but again this is only speculation but
my favorite theory is the fourth one
which is that Melania and by extension
mikola may have wanted radon dead for
the same reason that Rani eventually
does so that the Stars could resume
their movement bringing certain Fates
back into play and you might be asking
but why would mikola want the Stars to
resume their movement well perhaps
mikola's own fate was locked in stasis
we do find that demigod's Amber
Starlight shard in mikola's Hideaway
after all and I feel like it should be
concerning that his fate might have
fallen like this but the best answer I
think is that mikola wanted the Stars
Back In Motion so that the moon could
properly eclipse the sun this was a
ritual that Nicholas seemed to believe
Eve would revive Godwin the golden his
brother and we talk about this a lot
more in this video and I can definitely
see how the Stars being in stasis would
prevent the Moon from eclipsing the Sun
so I really like this answer but I'd
love to hear your theories surely there
is more than just these four options
but in the end there's only really one
answer that I'm confident in and it's
that we can't confidently see for sure
why Melania fought we're done not yet
anyway but whatever the reason it must
have been a good one because it was
during this battle that Melania
sacrificed everything
there is something I must return to
Melania the will that was once her own
the dignity
sense of self
that allowed her to resist the call of
the Scarlet rot The Pride she abandoned
to meet radon's measure
in Elden Ring's story trailers we see
this legendary fight play out clean Rock
Knights finally arrive with Melania
facing off against the red main Knights
and managed to plunge a ton of Spears
into radon during their Clash you can
actually see these Spears still sticking
out of his back to this day then Melania
and Rodan appear to be the only two left
standing Millennia sacrifices her
prosthetic arm to get close to Rodan
grabbing her blade and plunging it into
both of them giving us a close-up view
of the two characters here radon looks
monstrous which I theorize could again
be because he's tainted with The Madness
of a great Rune though that is just
speculation and we can also see
melania's lips moving here muttering
some final words or perhaps the
incantation for the Scarlet aeonia which
envelops herself and radon putting an
end to their fight in this video's first
chapter we talked extensively about
millennia's battle against the Scarlet
rot within her but in this moment she
seems to lose that fight maybe
intentionally and she allows the Scarlet
rot to take hold Millicent who is a
great parallel to Melania says that this
is when she sacrificed her dignity her
sense of self her will and her Pride
Melania did all of this just so that she
could meet radon's measure thus did the
Scarlet rot explode outwards infecting
Rodan and the Very land itself as their
battle came to a horrific standstill in
the end neither party was in a state to
continue fighting so technically Melania
didn't lose so she was technically still
undefeated
few survived the battle of aeonia but
one who did was the clean Rock Knight
Finley who in an unimaginable Act of
heroism carried the slumbering form of
Melania all the way back to the helic
tree they managed this alone fending off
all manner of foes along the way but
back at the center of caled melania's
scarlet Bloom remained
a nearby Phantom's dialogue reads
Sublime I tell you the very first flower
of Ionia bloomed on this very spot
Melania may you blossom into a goddess
in the present day caled features added
Center a giant tree that spirals in a
similar manner to melania's First
Scarlet Bloom so it probably is the same
Scarlet Bloom as the Phantom says this
was the very first flower of aeonia and
the beginning of the Scarlet swamp in
this land and at the very center of that
is another Curious Thing there's a boss
called Commander O'Neill who carries the
Commander's standard which reads even
after his Lord was fled Commander
O'Neill continued to brandish this flag
in the devastation of the rot eaten
field of battle the Seoul veteran who
remembers this battle with pride and
it's hard for me to say exactly whose
side O'Neill would have been on he
summons the spirits of exiled soldiers
who themselves have no real affiliation
to speak of though I will say that you
can summon one of Millicent's sisters to
help you in the fight against O'Neill
which might suggest that he's opposed to
the idea of rot and that he might have
fought for Adan although I feel like you
could go both ways on this because
Commander's standard says that his Lord
was fled and both Melania and Rodan fled
this battle anyway when you defeat
O'Neill by luring him into the guises of
scarlet Rock because it's funny he
doesn't just drop the Commander's
standard he also drops an heirloom of
the battle of aeonia a broken needle of
unalloyed gold that was once buried
within melania's own flesh repelling her
Scarlet rot until it snapped a really
interesting question here considering
the needle is broken is whether Melania
snapped the needle intentionally when
she plunged her blade into herself and
radon perhaps she knew that it would
cause the rot within her to flare up
worse than ever if the needle was broken
and allow her to defeat radon Millicent
does explain that the explosion of rot
in her is worse after she takes out the
needle almost as if it's been building
up inside them all this time
I pause to even tell you
but
took out the needle myself this Scarlet
Rock
worse than ever
so it's pretty clear that this is where
the final moments of the battle took
place and we even find clean Rock nights
able to rise outside when you're near
even now but then we don't find radon
anywhere near here instead we find him
closer to his former home at Red main
Castle in a nearby catacomb the spirits
of the war dead actually continue to
clash refusing to surrender even in
death and outside radon is exactly the
same way and while witless he's still
alive even managing to keep the stars in
stasis even now for his still in
possession of his great Rune which
itself started to burn to resist the
encroachment of the Scarlet rot his feet
have rotten off the spears of clean Rock
nights remain in his flesh but he fights
on simply using those Spears in his back
as arrows to fight off anyone who
threatens him refusing to give up and
die in anything but an honor death
are you one for festivals
or flowers to the South
a grand
Festival to make the stars turn
to the east
the heart and body part of a flower to
be
but there you enter
into the heart of the Scarlet rot
as The Rock takes hold caled becomes a
fresh hell and the land itself becomes a
threat even the dragons in this place
were forced to flee and they would make
a new Nest on a plateau that would be
dubbed Dragon Barrow and no one since
then has dared to enter it that said a
few dragons did not make it away
unscathed the dragon execis succumbed to
the Scarlet rot though he did not forget
his hatred and sadly Grail the mother of
all dragons who dwarfs them all as well
can be found on death's door surrounded
by her children and completely blighted
by the Scarlet rot kind of sad thanks
for the 50k runes though and in the end
it was melania's Scarlet rot not really
Millennia herself that would eventually
Drive rodan's red main Knights to defeat
according to their armor when they were
driven to defeat by melania's Scarlet
rot the red main Knights burned off the
crest on the left breast of their armor
to indicate their resolve stating alas
dear home I shine to see you again for
our duty is to remain here a bulwark
against the blight the knights using
fire to burn away their own Crest in
this way is such a great symbol for fire
was their one and only weapon for
fighting back against the rot and
interestingly according to the armorer's
cookbook a lot of these tools and
techniques to do with fire were passed
down by an armorer who served the great
General radon as his books contain
knowledge of dealing with rot the
application of fire in particular and so
this flame of the red Mains clearly
became a large part of their identity
henceforth corpses of rabid Wildlife
were piled high and burned long
smoldering walls of flame were built in
order to prevent the rot from spreading
to neighboring lands these same walls
border their own castles they burnt down
churches and they even managed to
commandeer some flame chariots to help
in their fight they utilized torches
fire pots arrows everything and
fittingly Knight gerund's beloved sword
a flamberg became the symbol of the
castle itself thanks to the flame-like
undulation that gives this sword it's
difficult to pronounce name and Jaron
himself remained at Red main Castle to
regularly host a celebration of War
calling champions from far and wide to
deliver death a death for his friend who
is now festering with rot and crippled
by Madness who now only wishes for an
honorable way out meanwhile amidst
melania's aeonian butterflies pale pests
emerge from the swamp of aeonia
though they appear to be mere bugs
they're not these creatures are
intelligent with a quote-unquote keen
intellect that allows them to craft
uncanny Weaponry from sharpened shell
they can encant spells as well and they
can even tame wild beasts that said they
are ultimately creatures of worship and
Gary actually calls them witless which
admittedly does contrast with them being
described as intelligent in this item
description regardless the pests are
also called the abandoned Children of
the goddess and Servants of the goddess
of rot who have been Forsaken and it's
not hard to see why not only was
Millennia carried far away at the very
moment of her Bloom when these pests
allegedly emerged but she resents and
resists the Scarlet rot inside her
unless she's pushed to the absolute
Brink so of course the pests are
abandoned in that sense as well and who
wouldn't hate them honestly is there
anything more annoying than this bloody
attack nevertheless the pests persist
they even have a quotable line of
dialogue in the Kindred of rot's
exaltation Talisman which reads rot for
the Scarlet goddess o Scarlet blossoms
flourish in distant lands and return to
us The Unwanted children which brings us
to the phrase Scarlet blossoms this
might not be talking about literal
flower buds of the Scarlet rot but
instead I think it's talking about
actual people I think it's talking about
these Five Sisters I think these are the
Scarlet blossoms they are polyana
Maureen Amy Mary and Millicent
girl Millicent she is apart green and
undeveloped waiting to flower into
magnificence
what a wondrous day that will be
in truth before her I'd never seen a
bird of such superior quality she might
very well outshine her sisters so it
seems like these pests including Gary
perhaps have a keen interest in
cultivating these Scarlet blossoms I'd
prefer to talk about Millicent's
questline in a future prepare to cry
episode so subscribe and turn on
notifications but I will hold off for
now but essentially gowri does all of
this in anticipation of these daughters
becoming Scarlet Valkyries who he
believes might one day serve Melania
when she ascends as the goddess of rot
at this point Melania hadn't been seen
for a long while not since she was
carried off to the helic tree and the
helic tree's location itself was a
mystery to many but there were still
those who venerated and worshiped her
and they weren't all pests some of them
were human like Mali Mirai the castellan
of the Shaded Castle
Mali wears the Mirai mask which is
something only worn by the head of house
Mirai it Bears the likeness of the first
of their line and it describes this long
dual history of the Mirai family who
served as both executioners and
castellans of the Shaded Castle so
fittingly their storied sword is the
Mirai Executioner's sword a broad-bladed
weapon that would eventually be used
against them 4. one day they made the
mistake of capturing a bell-bearing
hunter named elima but Elma who knew
battle skills that allowed him to move
objects with his very own will snatched
the sword from the sight of his looming
execution and overthrew his captors but
it doesn't seem like he wanted to rule
over the castle in their stead instead
the castle falls into ruin and when we
find him elima is just standing and
staring at an enormous portrait which is
a picture of Millennia who some believe
is to blame for the fate of the castle
a nearby Phantom laments the state of
things and States how samurai is ruined
just desserts for falling for that
severed Harpy no surprise that guilty
[__] took the castle and our storied
sword in the outskirts of the castle you
can actually find and fight Mali Mirai
the former castellan of the castle who
has now been ousted he wields the ant
spur Rapier which is a weapon that
evokes the Scorpion dagger that we
mentioned at the start of the video as
it's also a blade fashioned from a
chitinus creature in this case it's the
spur of a giant ant fittingly then its
description reminds us that Scarlet rot
is an old Legend and goes on to state
that Malay Mirai of the Shaded Castle
was a private believer in The Scarlet
rot and indeed he eventually found his
own personal goddess the Mirai robe
explains why he was so enamored with her
stating that the sons of Mirai are all
sickly born and so Mali murai was
beguiled by the beautiful and fierce
goddess who was born into rot Millennia
was after all a powerful and fierce
figure in spite of her Affliction so
it's easy to see why Malay Mirai looked
up to her though I guess it's possible
that he took this veneration too far as
the castle is found sinking into a
poisoned swamp and the throne room is
filled with prosthetics which mirror
melania's own indeed it's possible that
he even found melania's very own
prosthetic as you can loot the
valkyrie's prosthesis here which reads
golden prosthesis once used by the
one-armed Valkyrie a Masterwork of
craftsmanship with practice and skill it
can be used as proficiently as a real
arm when Malay Mirai lord of the Shaded
Castle embraced this prosthesis he
claimed to feel the presence of his
personal goddess
now I'm not really sure if this is
melania's actual prosthesis or not I
feel like you could make debates for and
against that but regardless it drives
home just how much of a fanboy this guy
was but in the end the castle is not
much more now than just a home for some
surviving clean Rock nights who would
understandably feel at home in such a
place and I guess they have nowhere else
to go as Melania Slumbers back at the
helic tree where she does very little
else until you arrive and Trigger what I
think is her second transformation
thank you
wait
the Scarlet bloom flowers once more
you will witness true horror
now rot
now I got some bad news for you guys in
this Final Chapter so you know how
difficult Melania was to defeat right
well what if I told you that wasn't her
final form it might not be for the
Scarlet aonia description reads each
time the Scarlet flower blooms
millennia's rot advances and with the
third blue she will become a true
goddess so it's known that melania's
first Bloom was in caled and we know
that she blooms in a fight against us so
the debate becomes is this mid-fight
Bloom melania's second bloom or her
third
some would argue that this is melania's
third bloom and that she's already
become the goddess of rot she does after
all literally have goddess of rot as her
title and there is a bloom right outside
her boss room which could have been the
sight of her second Bloom so how do you
argue against that well for starters the
Blue Mount side might not be hers for
one it'd be kind of weird if she had a
second Bloom that is never described
right here when she's slumbering in just
the neighboring room but not only that
in front of this Bloom you actually loot
the Traveler's set which is the same set
worn by Millicent and her sisters and
melaner as well considering Millicent
and her sisters are buds of Melania and
considering Millicent also leaves behind
one of these blooms when she dies it's
not ridiculous to think that one of
these sisters might have flowered here
already and I don't think that Melania
having goddess of rot in her boss title
means that much many like gowri and the
pests already believe that Melania is
the goddess of rot the Scarlet aeonia
description instead specifies that the
third bloom will make her a true goddess
and I think anything before that is just
a brief flash of the rod God shining
through but the biggest piece of
evidence that Millennia hasn't yet
reached her third bloom yet in my
opinion comes from gowri who goes to
extraordinary lengths to nurture
Millicent encouraging us to kill her
even just so this betrayal can turn her
into a Scarlet Valkyrie that will serve
millennia
it must be done by your hand no other
Millicent trusts you rather deeply in
fact sever that trust nurtured by
betrayal her bad will flower most
vividly when Melania ascends to godhood
Millicent II shall be reborn as a
Scarlet Valkyrie
if Millicent dies she flowers with
Gary's expectation being that she will
be revived after this so considering
that there's a bloom in melania's Boss
room as well that appears after you
defeat her I feel like it's possible
that Melania could have another
revivification after this as well and
one final piece of evidence was actually
pointed out by you guys in the comments
of my recent Oracle short in that video
I argued that the oracles might be there
to Herald the return of mikla as a God
as their Spirit ashes state that it is
said that when Oracle envoys appear
playing their pipes they do so to Herald
the arrival of a new God or age but I
completely neglected to mention that
they might be here to Herald melania's
Ascension as a god instead so thank you
guys for pointing that out if you
haven't already I'd appreciate if you
tried out some of my shorts content it's
extremely difficult to fit everything
within 60 seconds but it's a fun
Challenge and I'm pretty happy with some
of the short stories that I've been able
to tell in those shorts anyway
personally I wouldn't be surprised if we
fight some incarnation of Melania again
in the DLC and I'd be down for that
fight provided she rises again with her
lower half as a scorpion or something
but what I find to be the most
disturbing thought about melania's
potential third bloom is the gowri
believes a Scarlet Bloom will be more
Vivid if it's nurtured by betrayal
that's what we see in Millicent's
questline so what if millennia's third
bloom could be more Vivid if she's
betrayed by her brother mikola but it's
late now and I'm really getting into
some deranged speculation territory
aren't I so that's probably my cue to
end the video
special thanks to misspap for the
footage and editing help as always and
special thanks to quailug as well for
looking over this script and thank you
as always for watching
[Music]